- I think novelty gets a
little too much positive press.
(funky music)
♫ Oh
- Very excited, I was not often allowed
to eat Pop-Tarts as a child.
- I used to eat Pop-Tarts
every single morning
before going to school.
- Sometimes with soda-flavored items,
like they try to get that like fizz aspect
into the flavor, you know?
- And it never works.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause you can't mimic carbonation.
(whoosh)
- They did a rally lackluster
job on their swirl right here.
- It's too cursive-eese.
- Is it a Crush Pop-Tart?
- These look like eyes.
- Well should we give it a little sniff?
(sniffing)
It smells like cardboard.
(laughter)
- Oh no...
- Oh!
Orange soda.
You don't like it?
- No one has ever asked
for hot orange, like ever.
- Orange Pop Rocks in here, imagine that?
- Also they've got synergy
there, Pop-Tart, Pop Rocks.
Pop Rock Tarts.
- Look at that color, that's unnatural.
- Aww.
- It's pretty accurate,
I have to say they did really good.
- It tastes medicinal.
- (mumbled) give them to me.
(laughter)
(whooshing)
- I immediately like it because
it reminds me of a smore.
- Mmmm.
Oh my god you know what this must be?
- [Both] Root beer!
- If you just imagine a
root beet float though,
without any moisture.
That's what you're about to experience.
- Oh man you really sold that one.
- Yeah.
- Well, kind of, well...
- It kind of works better
than the orange one.
The root beer's a little
bit of a subtle flavor,
you know, a little whimsical
action, in the background.
- Whimsical.
- Okay.
On point, exactly the same.
- It really is.
- It just tastes like the
sugary part of root beer.
- Check this out.
Oh my god!
- Is it good?
- Oh my, beer and here
(laughter)
let me help you with that with that.
- (mumbling) right?
- It compliments it so well.
- Yeah.
- Listen, I think they
were all kind of weird.
- All two of them.
- It was enjoyable, but I don't think
I need to ever have it again.
- They're definitely
thinking outside the box
and that's respectable.
Maybe they should just, keeping
that inside the box, though.
- I would eat the frosting
off of the Pop-Tarts.
- How?
- You just...
- Oh, you...
- Yeah I mean you look like an idiot,
but damn do you feel ten blesses.
(laughter)